well you know me I just went through an
hour and a half of breaking down my
entire genome I went to health nucleus
where they look at everything full body
scan heart cat scan I'm good but the
best news is I I've avoided I'm not
predisposed to any kind of god forbid
but any kind of cancers died to me you
know like yeah exactly from from
genetics I don't have any weird genetics
my - nothing your family no cancer
nothing dude I'm very lucky that's thick
everybody everybody my family lives
forever and they don't get weird
diseases out that's just luck that's
just [ __ ] luck of the draw now might
die who [ __ ] knows I don't I don't
know pop accounts cholesterol he dick
well Papa Callaspo Papa Callan I know I
was I was high
I'll tell you what if you're high your
Papa's on hey what else is high and you
know this my testosterone my natural tie
don't take any TRT or any of that [ __ ]
and I have it I have my testosterone on
my natural testosterone is 1111 so 11
you just say 1100 for a lift for a 53
year old apparently that's off the
charts most guys my age I was getting
there with kid the guys who follow the
Sentry hundred you probably 300 400 yeah
I'm 1100 I'm over em so you have so much
energy now balding I know dude you guys
with high testosterone that's where they
go bald that's probably true they have
my dick they're always are always it's
always ready to go or is you ready to go
never had a problem with so now you
don't know you never have to kill auntie
Artie
well not for now but I was I remember I
told you I don't want to [ __ ] with my
endocrine systems I always felt I told
you I would long and athletic yeah
wouldn't you know I just felt you know
then you take that and you're freaking I
now what do you do then yeah no no I
don't want to [ __ ] with that
if it goes low and I'm feeling like I
don't have energy but my mother who I
take after my mother at 80 like my
mother tell you because I had energy all
day I feel fantastic
you've never had an issue my mother
walked when she was 65 she walked just
to see if she could do it she walked 26
miles in a clip she just walked just
watch straight yeah so you know that she
wants walk my blog she always had a she
still has energy yeah
and 86 my grandma and my uncle left oh
he's 96 that dude oh I haven't you know
what else I have I have the FOXO gene do
you know what that is that's the
longevity gene oh really that's that's
where I will live I have a very high
chance of living to 90 or over they
reach palm to they know this is all
genome stuff it's all science mmm health
nuclear it's Craig Venters your Viking
to let us say well no I've got I've got
I'm southern Italian and I'm um nor
Northwestern European uh-huh but no I've
got the Fox of gene Locke so let's call
the Foxes walk so look it up the FOXO
gene is a gene that some people have its
own longevity genes so the majority
people that live like if their cinterion
the box oj and the FOXO gene yeah that's
cool man tell me what I got I know
that's good I test I know
foxes gene all good news I don't like no
it don't my news your don't why are you
pissing on my parade right now I'm not
show you my whole [ __ ] I know I'm
sure they sing all these really do yeah
they did I know FOXO gene is real the
Fox Oh genes real yeah don't read your
text sir would your first day back in
studio man come on I'm just looking at
my I really get a text also uh yes oh
yeah 1100 I would say cost cost money I
don't like talking about this stuff
because none of it means anything cuz
you can die tomorrow for whatever reason
hmm police she a fox though yeah they
told you I lived to learn basically I
said nothing's wrong with me yeah so I'm
gonna live till - no - Tom 200 it's good
to know though yeah it's a good baseline
to know what kind of guess what I can't
take guess what's not good for me
hydrochloric we know the stuff you took
yeah so for me specifically if I take
that the drug you took when you had
kovin that's not good for some people I
happen to be one of them now I have I
get psoriasis so that can be a hint of
it but apparently that particular drug
and a couple of other drugs like from
diabetes and hypertension I shouldn't
take them because I have a certain gene
variation and and quinine or whatever
the [ __ ] that is that can cause
apparently my haemoglobin to shoot off a
bunch of iron in my liver
do some [ __ ] weird thing but you
wouldn't know that unless you did your
genome so I'm one of the few people
that's in that and then they told you
hydroxy Clark yeah sure and then you
can't eat nightshade
candy nightshades feel 100 percent it's
good thing he did that I'm very good
yeah can have nightshade I'll be honest
with you I think it's well worth you
have the gene where you can no sleep no
need my sleep sleep is everything did
they tell you never sleep they tell you
can't eat red meat yeah you know what
red meats not good for there you go red
meat for me because I have high iron not
good for Pompey to I guess you can't
break it down Craig Harris my Ferris
levels get higher liver and also my
cholesterol stay away from red meat
I don't like your attitude dude I don't
know when you walked out did they do
they give you the beats to piranhas
this is science dude no you don't okay
my chinos yeah sure are you mean every
Sunday in the park
no but I dabble back to check on a cyst
on my pancreas of course you do
you're the sisty little cysteine but a
small cyst on my pancreas yeah everyone
I'm sure it's nothing I'm one of my
brain yeah I don't like that he'll say
you gotta watch it just in case you get
one how do i watch it I'm like well
precancerous on your pancreas not a good
thing well how the [ __ ] did I watch it
though how do you keep an eye on your
father you know how do I keep an eye on
that that's when they told me at that
that benign tumor on my brain uh you
just keep an eye gets any bigger
well we mean you mean I'll know if I go
blind in one eye then I come back in
you're not a big hypochondriac cuz you
had some [ __ ] go on well you can't see
out of one eye all of a sudden I start
throwing up some bad times yeah but
you're through don't worry about it all
right do it
now let's pray go down there tear pull I
will say this when you're feeling low
energy and shitty like kovat did to me
you're nervous
here of death kind of goes away it's not
as strong cuz you're like I don't feel
good like people get really sick like
Alex Trebek who has pancreatic he was
like I'm done like if this one doesn't
pick up on things yeah I just don't I
know people who've gone through that
allows that was my uncle pax you know he
beat counts he had cancer
trafficking in
mouths and then he did chemo it took
away all ste Falls tastebuds so he can
taste and then it comes back here I'm
not doing it again I'm out
yeah I'm out my quality life is awful
yeah you think I'd rather just go that's
why Alex Trebek's in right yeah well you
you see you could understand that oh
yeah I guess most highly most awful yeah
it's like I don't want to keep live
another 10 to 12 years with other chemo
has to kill everything so so it killed
all the new cells that's why you lose
your hair and and stuff because you you
are tits of retrovirus cancer so you you
have to kill the actual virus and the
cells that it's you know that's kind of
how it works I think Jesus Chris yeah
it's it's we will find targeted
therapies and we are but yeah they said
it like you know gears will look back on
chemotherapy they're gonna laugh good
news on a covert vaccine right today
yeah Oxford came out the the you know
should have won by the end of the year I
can't wait I can't wait I don't know
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch it Tom what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]